let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
he's been on our show before i've
actually been on his show the dirty
moderate
with adam epstein adam epstein is going
to be joining us soon
i can't wait to talk to him i i really
here's the thing
me and him agree and disagree on darth
vader jr this is this is liz cheney i
called liz cheney darth vader jr we
agreed to disagree on a few things but i
think we agree on a few things and i
wanted to sort that out with adam on on
on the show here i wanted to sort it out
exactly what we agree on what we don't
agree on and i want to find some common
ground with a dirty moderate to to be
quite honest with you um he's been on
the show before you know him as the
dirty moderate adam epstein adam how are
you the dirty moderate is here tony i'm
always happy to see you hey it's it's
great it's great that you came to talk
to us about um darth vader jr but first
i want to uh get some business out of
the way here yeah it seems that the
elections last night um spoke loudly in
several areas uh new york's 19th i think
his name is pat ryan ryan yeah he's a
democrat he's a veteran um he was it
looked like he was about eight to ten
points down in the polls
in the polls prior to the election uh he
was he was poised to lose and last night
he won
big if you consider how much the polls
said he was down i guess my question is
this because that i think that is a big
reminder of what uh rachel biddikovers
called this morning row rage
um over this decision of dobbs but what
do you think about these polls because i
said last week i think the polls are are
way off um i don't know if the the
methods are antiquated or it's the
questions that they're asking or who
they're asking but they seem to be way
off with the kansas and now new york's
19th kansas with their no vote on the
referendum for uh bodily autonomy for
women um and now in new york's 19th they
just seem to be way off what's your take
on this well first of all i want to
congratulate pat ryan uh keeping that
hudson valley district it's a real
bellwether right that tells you um how
the politics are going i mean that was a
district that obama carried in uh
12
that uh uh trump got narrowly uh in 16
and then biden won narrowly in 20. so
first of all it is a very important omen
to look at swing races and and and take
data out of that
the second part of my answer is i think
the
effects of dobbs
easily i think the worst supreme court
decision since maybe dred scott versus
sanford you know i mean is is has
galvanized not just women tony and this
speaks to sort of where i come from
a lot of independent or independent
leaning women even republican-leaning
women
never thought that this would happen
right meaning that that they really
thought that they could vote for let's
say in the old days quaint times and
mitt romney or john mccain and you know
for fiscal reasons other reasons but
abortion wouldn't be ultimately taken
away that has proven itself demonstrably
false the religious right and the
right-wing nut jobs in tandem with maga
now for the last six years have created
a court
and an environment where that has
happened uh also the states the red
states they're going to try to do and
already doing horrible things like
banning abortion places like indiana and
idaho and stuff like that i think row
rage is real and i think that though
people are concerned about inflation and
gas and all of that it's coming down
um i think biden seems stronger than
he's than he seemed i don't know that uh
his approval rating will jack up all
that much but i think you might see a
year where
president's approval rating isn't great
but
certainly the senate
remains blue and maybe gets increased
and perhaps the house goes blue perhaps
i only say that because it's such a
narrow majority and there's been so much
gerrymandering on the right that i think
the republicans could still hold it
narrowly i hate to say that um but it's
possible they won't it's possible given
the new york the evidence of new york's
19th last night that we're going to see
uh uh that kind of 5248 in those purple
districts it's kind of that's what i
call it right a kind of democratic
edging out because moderates
democratic moderates people like me who
might have not me but i mean i might
have been inclined to the new yorker i
used to live in new york i used to vote
for new york republicans i wouldn't this
year you know what i mean because i
don't want to give these people another
seat to create gilead
quite frankly so hi gabe hey
so anyway yeah gabe is joining us here
and um
adam i i think you're i think you're
right on
i i will i will push back a little bit
in that i think last night is is uh hard
evidence that that the democrats are
actually in the lead in the house and i
and me and gabe have talked about how
these i hope you're right i said i
really hope i'm rooting for it i mean i
i just i just know that with the
narrowness of the majority the math may
not
in other words there may be too many
safe republican seats
to overcome
a to win a majority meaning the purples
the purple districts that are all up for
grabs there's about 25 of them i think
the majority of them will go blue if
alabama for example now has three
completely gerrymandered seats because
they put all black people in one
district to do that on purpose the
courts threw out the challenges they
have three seats they don't deserve
right there right you so i'm saying it's
a guaranteed republican seat people say
alabama no if if there could have been
swing districts in alabama they just
gerrymandered them out does that make
sense well yeah well and i mean i think
i think the republicans um whole point
in the gerrymandering in the census was
to cheat to win yeah i i don't i don't
think they were successful at
gerrymandering in some states like they
wanted to be
alabama is an example where they were
pretty successful in that effort um and
hopefully uh hopefully we can do things
to make sure to save our democracy and
give alabama an actual voice in our
house of representatives because they
when when they when you actually
gerrymander things like that um what you
do is you take away the voice of the
state right and alabama
now now has less representation in the
house of representatives they may think
they have more because now we have more
republicans but alabama as a state has
less of a voice inside that chamber
in the overall scheme of democracy now
speaking of house races yes and safe
house races there's one in particular
that i want to talk to you about of
course um i think it's in the state of
wyoming has two senators but they only
have one
house representative because of their
population size now you endorsed liz
cheney as sure dirty moderate um
i i actually wanted her to win that uh
primary race she lost two primary words
yeah um
i i think actually she's better
positioned um if she would like to take
power in the party where she's at by
losing that primary race i know that
sounds weird um but i think in the in
the actual political body that we have
now that she actually now is poised to
be the leader of what could be the old
guard gop
um because of how that race went now i
call her darth vader jr and i obviously
have a very strong opinions about liz
cheney but tell us why you endorsed her
maybe we can find some common ground
here
why you're a liz jenny fan well i mean i
think you first of all you know um i've
been on your program before you've been
on mine and i think you and gabe both
know my main cause is fighting for
democracy okay we say it dirty moderate
saving democracy one episode at a time
that is the paramount issue right now
tony the republican party as it stands
as a threat to democracy america our
freedoms our rights and everything okay
so
there are in regions of the country like
wyoming alaska's another one with
murkowski who i also endorsed
a democrat is not going to win in that
seat right so we have to start from that
the question then is who is the
republican in office that would you know
take up the mantle not for republicanism
democrats or even independents but
actually believe in democracy not be a
seditious [ __ ] like these people
are okay that was liz cheney clearly she
got blown out of the water because the
party's left her you know it's a trump
publican party that's what it is when
people say trump you know it's not his
party he's gone he's not gone he's very
much in the news he's actually
dominating the news cycle with his
um crimes of course but it's still but
it's but it i i think it's important to
say
who is going to stand up for democracy
first and foremost and i know your
listeners and you and i don't put words
in anybody's mouth you don't have issues
with their voting record number one
democracy trumps all so when people keep
saying
well i disagree with this channel and
everything but
i go you really kind of respectfully i
say you have it backwards there's no but
meaning in an authoritarian government
none of the things that anybody want
that most of us want certainly to the
left wants are going to happen if if if
we have president desantis and governor
mostriano and all these people you know
what i mean and harriet hageman none of
it so the first
order of business is securing the
democracy and liz does want to do that
one can take issue with her voting
record i don't agree with her on
everything i think i agree with her more
than you guys do but i certainly don't
agree with her and everything but that's
okay in a democracy because that's who
we are what's not okay is lying about an
election undermining the constitution uh
and actually perpetuating the belief
that the free fair transfer of power
didn't exist in 2020 right i mean it is
outrageous that we're still talking
about this ronald reagan called the
peaceful transfer of power a miracle
that it's a blessing of our democracy
ronald reagan wouldn't get the
nomination of this party i mean it's
obscene so to me
apart from the whether i agree with liz
cheney or not i always just feel like
i'm putting country first and i don't
want harriet hakem and those are my
choices it wasn't liz cheney and um
uh
who would it be i'm trying to think of
something liz cheney where someone i
would like liz cheney and um
uh alyssa slotnick in michigan or
something you know what i mean somebody
who's like a moderate abigail spanger in
virginia that wasn't the choice you're
talking about an old line constitutional
conservative and then a total [ __ ]
whack job i call her miss trunchville
from matilda but i probably shouldn't
well here's my pushback here's my
pushback and i and i and i i want to be
clear that i think we agree on a lot of
things here but we fundamentally
disagree on on one thing and that is the
one seat in wyoming and why that one
seat doesn't [ __ ] matter in the grand
scheme of things and it doesn't matter
if harriet
harriet weirdo whack-a-doo lunatic has
it or liz cheney and here's why okay
because those two people are going to
vote almost the exact same way
i know i know that i know that feels
like it's insignificant but that
fundamentally is the reason why they are
sent to the house of representatives is
to vote for those people wyoming and in
the grand scheme of things
liz cheney in my opinion is much better
position now politically to take control
of the party than if she was the
representative from wyoming now she is
now she is the person who is going to
absolutely throw dirt on trump's
political grave here i mean she's missed
it all i mean you have to give her
credit yeah no well and and here's
here's what i'll say about this by the
way let me interrupt you for a quick i
apologize the one thing i haven't done
that i think i've seen my liberal
friends do because they're excited is
lionize her in other words why don't
lionize any politician the reason i hate
trump cultism is
presidents are not kings politicians are
not rock stars i don't like i hate that
people are like yay you know brandon got
the gas prices down he did not he didn't
raise them and he didn't get them down
and i'm a supporter joe biden let's not
do what they do let's not let's not be
cultists anyway go ahead right no no so
so here's what i'll say about um
about liz cheney yeah darth vader jr is
that the voting record it didn't matter
who was gonna win that race it was
either if liz cheney won she was gonna
win the seat right if harriet lunatic
wins the carrylakewish.com carrie lake
wins that she's going to win that seat
and they're going to vote almost the
exact same way so the results on the
house floor exactly the same here's the
difference here's the biggest difference
to me
is that um harriet lunatic is not going
to be taken seriously at all um she's
actually going to be ostracized and
probably a pariah
within a matter of by the end of her
two-year
term at the house of representatives i
believe that the the people in wyoming
are smart enough to understand
when when they do see the results that
she doesn't get them um i do i think
they'll say that was a [ __ ] mistake
and the reason why it was a mistake is
because we played into this she's
against us thing because i don't think
liz cheney necessarily aim is for
democracy i actually believe
that liz cheney's aim rather rather it
gives us the actual results that we want
as pro-democracy people or not because
the way she votes
the what she is for
is not exactly liberal democracy it's
not exactly that way and i and and i
know i know i know that's a hard pill to
kind of swallow sometimes that there are
people who want to hail as heroes
because i want to say she's a hero but
she's not and the reason why she's not
is because she would do almost the exact
same things that trump did
besides maybe some of the crimes and
besides the crime against our democracy
because she knows it's a threat to her
power um but i do want to say and i do
want to give her credit here
when she is absolutely carrying the
shovel that will bury trumpism yeah but
um when she actually took the family
backhoe away from her dad to bury
trumpism and that ad that he put out
darth vader himself um to absolutely and
i don't think it was a rally cry around
liz cheney i think that ad more than
anything was a statement to republicans
all around the country and it was a
warning that hey
if you are attached to trump and you're
not attached to the cheney train
you're going to lose politically very
bad and you're not going to have a party
i believe that's what the message was
and the reason why is because dick
cheney was the only republican other
than his daughter who stood on the house
floor yep on january 6 2022
this year
to actually give remembrance to the
people who lost their lives and the
people who fought a battle against the
trump supporters who tried to create on
violent insurrection to overthrow our
vote they were the only two republicans
standing there with nancy pelosi which
is unheard of
is unheard of that that two republicans
would stand there so i agree with you
that i think liz cheney appears to be
for democracy um everything everything
would say that she does want our
democracy to survive so that she can
retain power inside of her own
republican party that is the way that i
think that is actually going on i don't
actually think that she wants uh full
equality full equity she doesn't want
bodily autonomy for women it's obvious
she said it she doesn't actually want to
have um sweeping voting reform to make
sure people have complete hundred
percent access to the ballot she doesn't
want those things um so to say that she
is for democracy
she may be but it's a different type of
democracy than what i think most people
are thinking of in in this country at
this moment in history right i mean
she's for the survival i mean to be
clear she's for the survival of the
country as well but
let me let me say something and you know
you may not like this and no go ahead no
no and the listeners may not like this
as an independent it gives me even if i
were a democrat it gives me no joy to
see the moral and philosophical collapse
of the party of lincoln what i mean by
that is i do not want to live we are a
two-party country i do not want to live
in a country that is all a dem
run entirely by democrats for the rest
of my life i just don't we need a center
right alternative that is not
kooka-dooka luka whack-a-doodle okay
that aren't election deniers that aren't
fraudsters that yeah are going to be
more right-wing than the democrats are
and i don't mean always far right-wing
they're just going to be more
conservative on the spectrum
to balance it out we are about attention
in our democracy but we have to compete
for ideas and while i'm not here to
vouch for liz cheney there is a
honorable strain of constitutional
conservatism that for a place like
wyoming and i don't think first of all
you put everything together i reject
that argument but not to say you know
everything is not voting and right it is
but let me say this let me
pull something out the people who are
ranchers in wyoming want the federal
government to leave them the [ __ ] alone
and they're right they don't want to be
taxed by washington it's i don't
understand why people can't understand
in the same way by the way that people
in blue cities and states you know what
i mean don't want red states dictating
their values to them we're still a
50-state country and i believe that and
i believe somebody can be sent to
washington with a different
philosophical bet i disagree with liz
cheney on a lot of things but i don't
disagree with her on everything because
i think she was representing her
district and i don't have to agree with
people to have this democracy to survive
and i know that's you know i'm not
listen i am voting blue and i do like
joe biden and i i've actually never
voted for a republican for president but
i also know that we have to have a
healthy republican party or we are
doomed if because and i'm just saying
this to you authoritarianism isn't owned
by the right history shows that and i
don't mean that if the democrats stay in
power all of a sudden going to have like
a stalin
government
but what i mean is what i'm pointing out
is absolutely you're saying brandon's a
communist that's what you're saying
that's right here you know i'm just
kidding i don't know i'm saying that i'm
saying that um absolute power corrupts
absolutely uh you see it in i'm sorry
you see in california you see it in blue
states where there's no check on the
power you see in red states you see it
in what's happening in missouri you see
what's happening in idaho you see in
places where of course there's blue
voters but it's like they're doing every
crazy thing they can do and i like a
government which finds itself kind of
wobbling in the middle i think that's
the best place to be by the way that
doesn't mean there's no progress it
means progress is moderated with reality
that's what that's the way i i
i i think we can find common ground here
because gabe me and you have talked
about on this show that really we i
think the the
the actual
tension that we have in the country is
we don't have two parties we actually
have a party who hates democracy who
wants to destroy it and we have a lot of
people who disagree on all sorts of
[ __ ] things
right yeah well the other thing i think
too to remember is like you know if you
were to look at the country as if it was
a company right and you have a let's say
a uh in that company of a team right you
would never want a team that is fully on
one side or at least and when i say that
i mean like you want to make sure that
your team is diverse in the way that we
approach different ideas experiences
anecdotes what have you right like we
can't have a completely right team
that's crazy we can have a completely
left team that
is one way or the other is crazy i mean
there are crazy people on both sides
there's a spectrum right
um
but having the ability to come you know
across the aisle crazy idea these days
considering the way that the parties are
kind of so polarized but you know if we
look at it like a an actual team right
the the
the companies or the board members or
whoever you want to describe them as
that are more successful are the ones
that come from a very different
background because they can approach
problems
from different experiences maybe one
time it's more left it's more right like
obviously right now we have seen
the country want to get away at least
the people who are more sane and kind of
uh logical thinking to get away from the
crazy right
because that side is what is
deteriorating the company from within
it's like you know it's the definition
of insanity right you're doing the same
thing over and over again expecting
different results and we've seen that in
the last five years from this side of
the right who have done everything that
is i mean even today right like
doing 20 to 10 to 20k in in student loan
forgiveness we've got people on the left
who aren't happy we've got people on the
right who are definitely not happy and i
think it's great i think that's right it
is great because it's great for the
american working class right
why why is it not great i mean that's
the thing and that's where and my why
i'm all my progressive friend they love
that because i'm for that and i'm for
universal healthcare i said yeah because
i each issue to me is not i'm not i
don't need to buy the entire
uh kate you know what i mean gabe i
don't even have an entire package i am
able to have an a la carte politics i
really think and that's to to my point
earlier look you guys know this and
those who follow me i'm a gay guy i
don't want anybody who's gonna fight
against lgbtq equality that's
nobody should want that but certainly i
would never vote against my own humanity
but i'd like a party and i and maybe
this is the growing pains that does
fundamentally believe
maybe they're the lincoln party in
voting rights and in human rights and
all those things and then we can have a
debate like the before times we get all
that out of the way no one's deciding
that women don't have a right to their
bodies no one's deciding telling trans
kids they can't have gender affirming
surgery all this crap that they're
trying to to just to divide us on and to
really hurt people but then i really do
want to have a debate about
limited government
or larger government
what we should do in terms of national
defense how we should do that uh what is
the role what kind of tax rate should we
have but these are these are luxuries
almost now because the other side
literally to cling to power is willing
to burn the american experiment but that
would be my dream in politics because i
as a independent would like to say well
yeah listen i really like what joe biden
has done 75 of the time i don't have to
like every single thing but yes i still
like the president i support him and
that's okay do you know what i mean but
i don't like in our politics and i by
the way i'm never both sides seeing it
because i don't the left is [ __ ]
crazy but i don't think they're
dangerous with the right you know what i
mean i think there's we have to
differentiate well how dare they want to
fix the climate and build decent roads
and high speed rail those are dangerous
things
make sure to make sure that you don't go
bankrupt when you have a medical bill
that's dangerous type [ __ ] to make sure
that your student debt is a situation
where you can survive and support a
family because that's what you went to
college for in the first place that's
dangerous type stuff that's dangerous
stuff i know it's dangerous
i know well that's that's why it's a
it's a what about ism i don't like but
what about but what i would say is is i
do think there are legitimate debates to
be had about how to govern that actually
do help people you know what i mean
there are many instances where
and remember i'm a good faith actor but
i'm not coming at this with some i'm not
some reagan republican who's like trying
to like you know
you know sit down you're trying to pull
a jedi mind
like you're right i'm not here but
here's what i'll say here's what i'll
say because because i i think i get what
you're saying but i think i think our
political body in this country is is not
two parties anymore it's not it's not
republican and democrat it's not
conservative and liberal and here's why
let me let me show you this video here
please this is this is this is darth
vader himself
we were talking about earlier
a guy that i loathed all those years i
never voted for them you know well
listen listen to what this guy says one
more time because i think this piece of
content is super important inside of
what america is going through right now
let's listen to our nation's 246-year
history there has never been an
individual who is a greater threat to
our republic than donald trump he tried
to steal the last election using lies
and violence to keep himself in power
after the voters had rejected him
he was a coward a real man wouldn't lie
to his supporters he lost his election
and he lost big i know it he knows it
and deep down i think most republicans
know it
lynn and i are so proud of liz for
standing up for the truth
doing what's right
honoring her oath to the constitution
and so many our party are too scared to
do so
liz is fearless she never backs down
from a fight there is nothing more
important she will ever do
than lead the effort to make sure donald
trump is never again near the oval
office okay so i'll cut it short there
because then he goes into phenomena
i wish
a guy like me is always yearn for the
[ __ ] ruthless cold-eyed cowboy to use
his macho [ __ ] for good no i mean you
know what i mean usually those kind of
guys are the guys that like trans people
are coming your neighborhood right right
this guy you know i mean i love i'm not
i hate to give dick cheney any credit
but i love that he is what he said never
in 246 years the guy's a coward you know
it deep down they know it i just
think about that but think about that
for a second adam yeah because i think
he's telling us he's telling us that
there's not two parties right now
there's not two parties you're
pretending that you're against democracy
even if even if you
belie know and believe deep down inside
of you that donald trump's a crook and
he's a criminal and he tried he tried to
steal
our dem i don't care who tried
he tried to take your way of life
regardless if you like him love him
whatever the [ __ ] you worship him you
wear clothes with his face on it or you
[ __ ] hate him he tried to steal your
way of life and i think that's what dick
cheney is actually saying in this tape
and i think more than that he's saying
because i i think
liz cheney dick cheney knew that she was
probably going to lose and this video
is a a launch and her losing is a launch
of her presidential campaign against
trump if he would decide to run um and i
think that's what i want to leave it on
i want to ask you since we're talking
about darth vader and darth vader jr
because i think this is an interesting
topic
is
does liz cheney does she run for
president
only if donald trump runs or does she
run uh if ron desantis runs she kind of
told ron desantis a couple weeks ago to
to go [ __ ] himself yeah she said he's
not so many right so so i don't know if
she's setting up to where she's gonna
run against any trumpism or just trump
himself what do you think
i
i only think i can answer because i
don't have enough knowledge i don't
think anybody does but i mean my most
informed speculation says that
don't [ __ ] with the cheneys
okay
and no i really i mean you know like
them or don't like them don't [ __ ] with
them and they despise what trump has
done to the republican party right to
your point too it doesn't make them
angels but i also think it does make
villains um
they
i think liz would like to exact revenge
and i think she means it when she says
which to me is my rallying cry we all
have to do everything we can to make
sure that unfit
piece of [ __ ] bargain basement mussolini
never gets anywhere near the white house
again and that goal to me and i by the
way i apply the same thing to ron
desantis i think he's a dangerous
lunatic
and smarter too a much smarter lunatic
but
trump is still in the forefront and i
think that yeah she could run
against him to sort of make it a harder
run i mean i know there's and then
there's a lot of talk about would she
run as an independent and what would
that mean
that needs to be looked at you know i
mean i always for i originally said well
she would ross perot you know how ross
perot helped bill clinton get elected in
92 took 19 of the vote from bush but
then would she pull swing voters away
and hurt the democrat i don't know we
don't know that but i i she knows she's
not going to be elected because she
can't get the republican nomination she
obviously can't get the democratic
nomination so but she
she might do it to to cause ruckus
because i actually think
in in the way that um
in the way that she's been fighting for
democracy apart from however she's voted
she does want yeah she does want a
conservative republican party but she
wants one that's not tainted by lies and
deceit i do i do think that and i think
that's what she'd like to get back to
does that mean she gets more power of
course but politics is about power i
mean if we're going to talk about who
democrats want you know what i mean i
mean look at they're all lining up to
run power is inherent and i don't
criticize them for that that's part of
the game you know right
you have to have power to set policy
yeah i mean you know whenever they say
oh so and so is presidential ambitions
well if they're popular in politics and
beloved and in the senate or higher yeah
of course as opposed to what i mean
i mean you know they're not running for
the you know to me to the head of
radiology in a hospital i mean they're
trying to
adam
adam adam i think maybe we should elect
our radiologist at the hospital give us
give us one last push i wanna i wanna
hear i wanna hear a shameless plug from
you tell the audience where they can
find adam epstein the dirty moderate
with adam and where can they find it all
right you can you can find our podcast
anywhere you get your podcasts we're
everywhere apple google spotify
amazon you know the whole list we are at
twitter uh at dirtymoderate on twitter i
also my personal account overlaps with
that it's at adam epstein prod so those
are my twitter accounts and then
instagram of course where i try to keep
a viable presence is at dirty moderate
and at the real adam epstein so i know i
just gave you a lot but no
go go follow adam adam on the socials
the socials the socials you know the the
the grammy grams and the tweety tweets
that's what they are here that's what
they are here uh you know i'm gabe makes
fun of me because i'm a boomer that's
what he says
actually i think you called me a
hillbilly in the texas yeah last night
because you're like my internet's not
working and i was like yeah my internet
was down
my internet was down yesterday so
apparently us in the hills us and the
sticks and get called hillbilly when we
now i will say adam just for the record
my internet hell of a lot better than
gabe's when it is up and running when it
is up and running wow you know
the internet against high you know
high-speed internet out here in l.a very
red state there you're competitive i
don't know
let me allow me also generosity of
spirit tony i love being on your show i
love when you come on my show gabe i
love your comedy and all your posts they
i live for them kind of they're amazing
they'll both you're amazing stuff so i
love being in touch with you guys and
appearing and don't get his head too big
don't get it
i'm wearing a hat today oh my god
this guy
thanks thanks adam for joining us
everyone go follow the dirty moderate
with adam epstein on anywhere where you
find your podcast and i think we can
agree on one thing let's not take the
shovel out of liz cheney's hand as she's
digging the grave for trumpism adam
thank you for joining us everyone stick
around we'll be right back right after
these messages i voted for the
pain-capable bill the fetal heartbeat
bill fetal heartbeat has been for
six weeks now the second week that this
that the fetal heartbeat bill became law
a doctor called me a 19 year old girl
appeared at the er she was 15 weeks
pregnant her water broke and the the
fetus was unviable the standard of care
was to advise her
that they could extract or she could go
home the attorneys told the doctors that
because of the fetal heartbeat bill
because that 15 week old had a heartbeat
the doctors could not extract they're
out for blood i'm telling you they're
out for blood and these state races are
important let me show you why this
happened in south carolina i believe
this was the end of last week this guy's
name is collins again this is in south
carolina i believe in their house their
house chamber um because he's a
representative he's not a senator here
so it would be reflective of their house
chamber in the state of carolina i'm not
sure exactly how their legislators made
up in carolina but this is an elected
official now he voted to take away
women's rights in a personhood bill he
describes it here and then he starts to
talk about how he almost immediately
regrets it now i'm gonna rip this
[ __ ] apart because i actually
think we should not give this son of a
[ __ ] any kind of credit here [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him and anyone who thinks like him
at this point everyone's like oh well we
should invite them over to our side our
side [ __ ] you this guy abstained from
another vote that took it even further
even after he made this speech he didn't
vote against that bill he abstained and
by abstaining he's only [ __ ] giving
credence to their bigotry and their and
their [ __ ] fascism here but listen to
how he regrets his vote because he
didn't fully understand the
ramifications of him voting for
legislation this is the most boneheaded
[ __ ] thing i have ever heard in my
life that a politician doesn't
understand that when they vote on
[ __ ] legislation that it affects
their constituents you piece of [ __ ]
[ __ ] let's listen i'll move to
my final comments then mr chairman
i voted for the pain-capable bill
the fetal heartbeat bill
and fetal heartbeat has been for
six weeks now neil collins is this guy's
name by the way representative neil
collins and notice he's on the judiciary
special laws committee this [ __ ]
the second week that this that the fetal
heartbeat bill became all a doctor
called me
out of anderson i live in easley a 19
year old girl appeared at the er she was
50. so now a 19 year old's a girl by the
way
now to them a 19 year old's a girl well
she's you know she's a teenager so she's
still a girl i mean i would agree but
now to them now they're changing their
mind yeah [ __ ] this [ __ ] here
15 weeks pregnant
her
water broke and the the fetus was
unviable
the standard of care was to advise her
uh that they could extract or she could
go home the attorneys told the doctors
that because of the fetal heartbeat bill
because that 15 week old had a heartbeat
the doctors could not extract so their
only choices were to
now you notice because this is why i
think this motherfucker's a coward
he's a [ __ ] coward now he's sitting
here and he's saying these things and
people are like well at least he had the
gumption to speak up here well frankly
he did a dereliction in duty by speaking
up like this and then abstaining from a
vote against what he uh what he's saying
is gonna harm his constituents here he's
a weak piece of [ __ ] and frankly in my
mind he didn't go far enough someone who
wasn't a coward would not only speak
spoke up but use their vote in support
of their [ __ ] constituents but you
notice how he blames it he blames it on
the attorneys did you see that did you
notice that little
thing there well yeah i mean they're
never gonna take they're never gonna
take uh responsibility they're never
gonna say hey
look i won didn't read the bill when i
voted on it two i never really thought
of what the
outcomes or possibilities or like edge
cases could be if somebody was pregnant
despite the fact that there were other
people on the other side of the aisle
that said you haven't thought this
[ __ ] thing through
and when it does come back to bite you
in the ass you're not going to be able
to point fingers because you were the
one who voted on you're the one who put
your stamp of approval to say yes it
should be illegal after six weeks to
have an abortion and now
you have someone that's just a county
over just a town over whatever and you
feel for that person but you have just
no ability despite the fact that you
have the power to now vote against it
you go
i would love to vote against it but i
can't because i would get torched
rebecca on um
facebook points out and she says what
the [ __ ]
you can't go home after your water
breaks you can get an infection and or
is harmful to the baby yeah just wait
that's the thing that's the thing here
the republicans want to force the
doctors to not do the thing that i don't
know they were educated do which is
medicine and send these women home with
this fear of infection and dying watch
admit the 19 year old until that fetal
heartbeat stopped i asked how long does
it take to stop
she said
seconds minutes hours maybe days
or discharge
they discharge that 19 year old
the doctor told me at that point there's
a 50 chance well first
she's going to pass this fetus in the
toilet
she's gonna have to deal with that on
her own there's a 50 percent chance
greater than 50 chance that she's going
to lose her uterus there's a 10 chance
that she will develop sepsis and herself
die that weighs on me i voted for that
bill these are affecting people oh oh my
god
can you imagine can you imagine bill
a bill
a bill affecting people gabe if you vote
on let you are you telling me that
that's what policy and government does
are you telling me that when we elect
these officials to make decisions for us
us the government when they represent us
as the government you mean the decisions
and the votes that they take affect us
are you serious this is ridiculous how
[ __ ] how ridiculous is this that
these people have to weigh this on their
mind yeah it's crazy that uh you know
just like trump's lawyers learning about
constitutional law it's almost like
these people who are in office are like
getting like a civics lesson and
understanding how policy making is done
and that when you vote on something it's
not just for you to say well it doesn't
affect me so
i don't give a [ __ ] but now that you
have constituents or people that are
coming to you and saying this you're
like oh i feel for that person because
yeah it is incredibly [ __ ] up that
somebody would have to have a an uh you
know can't get an abortion even though
that is the recommended procedure when
you have this happen to you and they say
nope you know what you have to now keep
that dead fetus in your body and you
could possibly die you get sepsis you
get an infection you can get sick right
like your health is at risk so because
of the baby
or the the fetus you know stopped and
and your and your body was like hey look
this is this is not going to
not going to work out republicans like
nope got to keep it that's how [ __ ] up
that is and this guy's like oh man like
this is so messed up yeah what the [ __ ]
did you think was gonna happen when you
decided to say six weeks was the bare
minimum or rather the maximum of when
you could get an abortion i mean here's
the thing the reason why he really is
upset gabe the reason why he's upset is
not because of the life of this 19 year
old there's nothing to do with it not
because other people could be affected
he's affected by this and the reason why
he's affected by this is because he was
roped into these conversations and now
he's in a position where he has to
defend his vote how dare you how dare
you
as constituents get me in a situation
where i now have to defend my vile vote
to take your rights away what the hell's
wrong with you don't if you are
affecting me because that's really what
he's saying here right listen to the end
here this affects him that's why he's
pissed off here that's why i don't give
a [ __ ] about this guy i don't care what
the [ __ ] story he told the way he told
it here it's about him the whole [ __ ]
thing is about him well he's the victim
tony he has absolutely no responsibility
i'm the victim i feel the pain even
though this
this teenage 19 year old girl was the
one who had to go through this very
traumatic physical and emotional just
stress and trauma and he goes
yeah [ __ ] it
that is what it is someone's asking he
abstain yes he does abstain you'll see
the end of the clip where he says he's
going to abstain watch and we're having
a meeting about this it took that whole
week i did not sleep see wow
see why i told you this [ __ ] i
followed up with the doctor a week later
yeah she had heard nothing did not know
about the night thank god i followed up
two weeks later she did return to the er
they did extract the now non-beating
fetus thank god they did an abortion on
here do you hear this guy yeah you hear
this [ __ ] this forced birther
thank god he says because i was losing
sleep oh my god well well well thank god
for representative collins that this 19
year old girl finally was able to get a
medical procedure to save her life
because he voted for a [ __ ] bill and
he couldn't get sleep since he voted for
it this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him and anyone like him [ __ ] him
everyone hailed this guy over the
weekend and he's some kind of [ __ ]
hero for speaking out he's not speaking
out for her he's speaking out for
himself [ __ ] yeah again it is all the it
is the projection it is the guilt it is
the gaslighting it is i'm the victim
i'm the one who really experienced the
trauma and i want to say that in order
for me to sleep well at night i am
staying tony here here he is and it
cleanses just like [ __ ] clean slate i
abstain it's like you go to church and
you're like forgive me father for i have
sinned and then a chur and then the
priest says okay let me get ten hail
marys and five our fathers and you
should be good and you're like okay cool
here's his conscience being cleared here
what we do matters thank you oh [ __ ]
that [ __ ] one second mr chairman i'm
almost finished shut the [ __ ] up out of
respect for the process i'm not voting
today but i want it to be clear that
myself and many others are not in a
position to vote for this bill without
significant changes
i'm not in a position to vote today i
abstain yeah what a pile of [ __ ] he's
crying he's crying because of a decision
he made
you made this decision we people have
been saying this about this [ __ ] for
decades and decades and decades if you
go down the slippery slope it will cost
people their [ __ ] lives it'll cost
them their lives it's not some kind of
[ __ ] liberal [ __ ] conspiracy
theory where we're trying to make you
have a certain religion or force you to
have abortions you are forcing people to
have birth you are forced birthers you
are not pro-life yeah you are not
pro-life collins and you still are not
pro-life you are still a force birther
because you abstain you won't show your
voice to make sure to protect that
19-year-old and women like her and their
bodily autonomy and their privacy to
make decisions that could save or affect
their life piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
him i don't want to hear anyone talking
about how much of a hero this guy is
[ __ ] i think i think the part of the
video that um that almost pissed me off
on like as much as him saying despite me
saying this very very sad and realistic
but depressing story about this young
girl having to go through this event
this dramatic event it's the woman next
to him that like consoles him and i'm
like are you [ __ ] serious right now
[ __ ] that [ __ ] like going one going
against your own side like as a woman
that you're like oh yeah yeah well it
really [ __ ] sucks for that girl and
this woman's like oh you're oh my god
i'm sorry like are you gonna tear up i'm
here let me just let me just like
brush your shoulder and your arm give me
a [ __ ] break dude poor guy like what
a poor guy he lost sleep gabe he lost
sleep i can't imagine him
oh my god he lost sleep for one week let
alone all the women out there who can't
make [ __ ] medical decisions about
their goddamn body like he he's upset
for one week he's like i couldn't sleep
i lost sleep for a week and then he
tells a story like origi like originally
when i heard this video and he was like
oh i followed up with the doctor and the
doctor didn't hear anything a week went
by and the worst thought in my mind
happened which was that the girl didn't
survive right she got an infection she
died or something very terrible happened
right because her life was at risk she
was carrying a dead fetus in her body
that could hurt her own health and so
when he originally said oh i followed up
and the doctor didn't hurt hear from her
i was like oh [ __ ] yeah you're thinking
you're thinking i was like the story is
going not the way that i want so when i
hear him say oh i lost sleep for a week
well imagine if this girl had lost sleep
well for the rest of her life because
she died and he goes well and it's
likely
it's likely with this with them not
being able to make this procedure and
discharging her it is likely that she
will never be able to have children talk
about talk about being pro-life talk
about being pro-fucking life and then he
has the goal to thank god that's what
pisses me off the most when he thanks
god that they were able to do that that
abortion you piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you
piece of vile trash
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking